let's do the inflation data first uh 5.3
uh cpi 4 core inflation what's your read
on these numbers
well you know first of all you have to
take them in context i mean this is the
first report that we've received now
in nine months that was lower than
expected
uh so they were looking for point four
for the month and we got point three but
you know most of the time we get a much
bigger number so a lot of people are
taking a lot of solace in the fact that
we finally have one number
we broke a nine a month streak of having
worse than expected numbers and now we
get one number that's
not as bad as expected and somehow we're
out of the woods i think that's
ridiculous you know if you annualize
even that point three
that annualizes to four percent
inflation a year which in and of itself
is pretty bad but if you look at the
actual
increase in consumer prices in the first
eight months of this calendar year and
then annualize that that's six point
four percent so we're still triple
the two percent that the fed is claiming
it's the target you know it says it
wants to be slightly above two percent
right well we're not even in the
neighborhood of two percent and the
number would be much much higher
if the government was not using owner's
equivalent rent which is you know like a
third of the index and this number is
supposed to represent housing costs but
it doesn't even come close because if
you look at what's actually happening to
rents or home prices we've never seen
these kind of increases these are
double-digit increases in the cost of
buying or renting a home yet none of
that is reflected in the cpi in fact the
government claims that
shelter prices are rising so slowly that
it's actually weighing down the cpi the
number would be much higher obviously if
we use the real rate of increase of rent
or home prices not what the government
is pretending uh the increase is okay so
one of the things i want to talk to you
about is uh there's obviously when you
have data people can manipulate that
data massage the data to say all kinds
of things so i could take the data that
came out today and i could make an
argument that uh inflation is going down
and it's a really positive story i could
take the data and paint a picture that
it's uh really bad and everything uh the
world's gonna end whatever explain
around housing specifically what is the
data that you're looking at where you're
saying to yourself okay this data is
showing very high and rapid price
appreciation and then explain what the
cpi number accounts for what the
difference between those two things are
well the see the housing component i
think owner's equivalent rent in august
which is the month we got today uh they
have us 0.2 is the increase and i think
year over year i'm not even sure if it's
set three percent
but if you look at housing prices year
over they're up almost 20 like 19 or
something like that this is one of the
biggest years ever
for home prices and if you look at rents
i think rents year over year are up
about 13
and that's based on companies that
actually track rents right uh websites
that you know are tracking what homes
are renting for so the real data is at
odds
with the government data the real data
is much much higher and of course
everything associated with home
ownership your utility bills are going
way up your insurance costs are going
way up your your taxes are going up so
every aspect of renting or buying a home
is going up in addition to what it costs
you to buy it or rent it uh and it's not
of course not just shelter components
that are going up everything is getting
more expensive and if people think
that's transitory it's because they
don't understand the problem in fact
they don't even understand inflation or
where it comes from because inflation is
about money you're inflating the money
supply that's what's being expanded and
none of this is transitory because these
deficits aren't transitory the money
printing isn't transitory it's here to
stay we're at qe infinity
the fed's balance sheet is going to
continue to expand and that means prices
are going to keep going up because we
continue to destroy the value of the
dollar as we expand the supply
when you think about the term transitory
we talked about it a little bit earlier
where it's just the definition is not
permanent so there's no kind of
quantifiable hey it's above this percent
for you know this number of years or
anything like that what do you think uh
is the
metric that would have to be hit in
order to qualify as transitory is it
something where cpi all of a sudden went
sub two percent uh next month then you
bet yeah it was transitory or have we
already breached uh kind of the the idea
of transitory inflation and we're well
now into a kind of a permanent um you
know kind of status
well the federal reserve already changed
the definition of transitory because in
the beginning the way it defined
transitory at least you know when you
heard their explanation
it meant a temporary increase in prices
that would go away so in other words
prices came up because of the reopening
of the economy because of some supply
bottlenecks but once the economy
reopened and those bottlenecks
uh you know cleared up the prices that
went up would come right back down to
where they were so that's what most
people
believe transitory was that prices will
be high for a while but then they're
going to come back down to where they
would have been
the fed has already backtracked on that
initial definition according to the fed
now
the price increases that they're saying
are transitory are in fact permanent
that we're never going to have a
reduction in prices they're going to
stay at this higher level what the fed
now means by transitory
is once prices stop going up
by eight percent or ten percent a year
they will go back to only going up by
two percent a year but those two percent
per year increases will be on top of all
these increases that we already
experienced so in other words if we get
a transitory let's say 20 increase in
prices
that 20 price increases we're going to
be living with that forever in fact then
we're going to get 2 per year in
addition to that so to me that really
represents a massive inflation tax
because you're going to need 20 more
money to buy the same amount of stuff
that you were able to buy before the
transitory period uh you know took place
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofi
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
you